how does southeastern wisconsin fit into
this national
election picture it's it's battleground
zero
right we've always been a battleground
but always at the end of these elections
it seems to have faded away and other
states have become more
focused um i think wisconsin is a great
place and i think that even when we have
differences we can
have a beer and a brat right roughly
half of america's voters live in the
suburbs and in the final months of the
campaign
as president trump seeks to boost his
support in those communities he has
zeroed in on the threat of violent crime
the suburbs are coming big to us because
the suburbs are next
if you elected this guy the suburbs
would be overwhelmed
with violence and crime and wisconsin a
swing state
is likely to be some of the most fought
over ground in 2016
president trump won here by fewer than
23 000 votes
he will win wisconsin with its 10
electoral votes he's cracked the
so-called
blue wall a marquette law school poll of
likely wisconsin voters from early
september
showed former vice president joe biden
leading president trump
47 to 43 percent three suburban counties
around milwaukee
serve as a gop counterweight to the
traditionally large democratic margins
recorded in the state's two largest
cities
milwaukee and madison the president will
likely need to win
big in the suburban counties if he wants
to take the state again
we sat down with a group of voters from
waukesha and ozaukee counties
half voted for trump and half voted for
clinton in 2016
to discuss the coronavirus pandemic the
economy
policing and how they are weighing a
sudden supreme court vacancy
as they think about november's election
did anybody
um really sort of struggle with that
decision in 2016.
i actually voted republican in 2008 and
2012.
and then in 2016 i voted democrat for
the first time
and my case was because of the person
instead of the party
i couldn't vote for donald trump raise
your hands if you plan to vote for
for president trump between now and
november
and who plans to vote for joe biden
sabrina it seemed like your hand raised
on joe biden was a little bit
lukewarm yes i do want him to show up
more strongly on some issues so i'm
still
listening closely he might not get your
vote
it's completely possible yes on memorial
day weekend
uh george floyd was killed in
minneapolis
uh neighboring state uh to wisconsin and
then
um subsequently in the summer uh
another man was shot in kenosha by
police
i want to get your sense for sort of the
black lives matter
movement uh there's been calls for
police reform
um it's obviously a a challenging
topic to talk about race in america but
but let's try to talk about it a little
bit and
and see where you're feeling in terms of
how these protests have gone
sometimes they've they've moved into
riots
uh and what you think should be done in
terms of police reform
there's over 700 000 law enforcement in
the country right now
that we can expect those human beings in
those situations those conditions with
that responsibility
to act flawlessly is ridiculous and what
is even more childish just think that
we can improve that by reducing the
amount of law enforcement
it's super unfortunate that there are
situations
like floyd that do arise but when it
comes to the numbers itself and the
interaction and the people we're dealing
with
there are people um yeah there could be
a little bit more reform in terms of
making people accountable for their jobs
in the proper way
and making sure they're not on the force
if they're if they're not capable
sabrina you've talked a little bit about
the segregation that exists in this
metropolitan area what is your take it
would be hypocritical
to be an american per se and not
understand that
we have a history of violence in this
country unfortunately change has come
through violence it's not the way that i
want it to be i'd love to come to the
table and talk it out and just get rid
of the ills of our country but that's
not what happens
so understanding that racism has seeped
into so many parts of our country
um just so it's it's just as american as
apple pie right
um there has to be reform within health
care there has to be reform within
housing there has to be reform within
the criminal justice system there has to
be reform in immigration we have all
these
areas that we have to dismantle racism
in
become aware of our unconscious bias and
choose
justice when they talk about well only a
few
people have been shot or killed or
whatever that's just the tip of the
iceberg it's really a lot more than just
a few bad apples it's really systematic
i do feel you know that trump really
incites
the violence and incites the devices and
incites a lot of the hate
the root of the problem is systemic
racism we can't just turn a blind eye
and say oh
you know everything's fine you know and
it starts with
opportunities and and the economy like
you said you know we have a segregated
city
look at the resources we're providing to
to the south side and the north side of
milwaukee versus
you know a predominantly you know white
area like brookfield
you know and in waukesha county you know
the resources are
you know day and night how do we expect
people to be okay
sue your turn what's what are your
observations about the
the summer of unrest that took place in
this country well i guess i don't
understand why people think it's trump's
fault that all this is going on
i was always taught as a young child
growing up that
if a police officer tells you to stop
you stop i don't care what color you are
black white yellow or purple
these people deal with people that are
on drugs
people that are crazy and so i could see
how some of these police officers are an
edge now are some of them taking it way
too far
yes they do believe so and i'm not
saying they were right in
in what i think is torturing george
floyd that certainly is not right
but there needs to be a little bit of
um acceptance on both sides that both
sides did wrong
tamira rice was shot before he had any
chance to respond to any kind of police
order
so the narrative that people aren't
following directions
isn't completely true unfortunately i've
had police approach me with their hands
are literally
on their weapon as they're coming up to
me and my kids are right there
seeing this so it's not that folks are
necessarily attempting to
not listen to police i think that
narrative has to go
my father is a retired police officer so
i have the utmost
respect for police um and i think a big
problem too is a lot of the word
the words we use the terminology defund
the police you know that's a bad term i
wish nobody had put that term out there
it's not about taking away money or
taking away police officers it's really
most of us want we want better education
for police officers we want more support
for them some social workers coming in
on some of these calls
sabrina can you just talk a little bit
about about your vote and how you are
feeling about
uh former vice president joe biden i i
do feel like joe biden recently he
started a campaign more lisa his team
started the campaign of being more
harsh on you know variety when i think
about philando castillo
and being murdered in minnesota and then
i think about what happened with george
floyd being murdered in
minnesota again same place same kind of
injustice but there wasn't really
change or a movement until george floyd
was murdered and the
public had an uprising same state
um so people don't listen until things
get
out of hand per se so i really don't
like the messaging
of joe biden i do want him to stand
with the fact that there's injustice
that needs to be fixed
there are people being crushed
underneath these systems and they
are americans also and when we say
defund the police we definitely mean it
i don't want to i don't want to lose
that message either
we do need to defund the police um
because
we want systems that actually do support
people and the ways
that policing cannot we're sitting down
just days after the passing of ruth
bader ginsburg
leaving a seat open on the supreme court
how many of you think that seat should
be filled
still during donald trump's first term
well obviously we have a constitution
it's
by the advice and consent of the senate
the senate is republican
if the president wants to put forward
his nominee he has his right he's still
the president until january
well i agree with chris i'm not
qualified though is one thing that
concerns me the most is what
implications will be on the election if
in fact
president trump and the senate goes
forward with the nomination
i'd hate to think that pushing this
forward would put
uh president trump's re-election at risk
or some of the uh the senators are up
for re-election
sabrina talk a little bit about why why
you don't think it should be filled this
year
just looking at the last example of the
way that republicans stood up and said
no barack obama cannot
bring somebody into this role when he
had more time than this one
then i would say the same thing let's
pivot to a subject that really has
dominated obviously
all of our lives practically all year
and that's the that's the pandemic
how many of you routinely wear a mask
when you go out in public pretty much
anywhere well it depends i mean if i'm
watching a place where i know there's
going to be a lot of people there of
course i will wear a mask
but if i'm taking my dogs for a walk by
myself
i'm not going to put a mask on well
again it goes back to the inconsistent
messaging about the effectiveness of
mass
there is there's a like a virtual
signaling issue with mass
out there at this point as well um it
does come down to
sort of what are our rights as citizens
the president has talked about having a
vaccine
potentially uh in time for the election
what do you all think of that who do you
believe when it comes to
the vaccine to try to get a vaccine out
and and
mass produced and and available in a
matter of weeks or months is
not it's not possible it's not safe who
all do you listen to
in terms of trusting what to know about
the vaccine who who
do you trust in terms of that topic i
think it was hard when the cdc came out
or somebody came out and originally said
masks don't help don't use masks
um and that made it really hard for a
lot of people to trust
but i think we didn't know what we
didn't know and we shouldn't have you
know assumed that we knew something
i i definitely i still listen to file
sheets i still i try to trust the cdc
um i think unfortunately they've been
influenced um politically when they
shouldn't be
but i think they're still um a reputable
source
chris who do you trust uh in on this
topic
well it's what's stunning to me i think
is doctors are starting to sound like
lawyers there's a lot of
different opinions and none of them seem
to agree which always worries me
my nephew was just diagnosed with covin
asymptomatic no issues um i have two
assistants
one of my assistants got coveted so it's
affected me personally but
i'm not sure who to believe on it has
anybody on the panel lost
a job or significant piece of income
because of the pandemic so i own a
private practice
optometric practice and so we were
forced to close
so i ended up having to lay off my
entire staff
are you open again yeah give me
uh your sense for how you think
president trump has handled this
situation
i think he's done a good job as far as
letting the states determine
each individual state on how they want
to handle it because
you know when new york was being so
burdened wisconsin had nothing
we can't blame trump for the the virus
of course and i
i don't even really blame him for his
initial actions or inactions
but i think now especially months six
months plus later
you know holding and having these
rallies political rallies with
hundreds of people or sometimes even
thousands in a closed space
you know without masks and him
continuing to you know
taunt people or make fun of people who
wear masks including joe biden
um i think to me that is the that is
probably the
what bothers me the most we should not
have this many people in the united
states who died from this
so the response was not quick enough it
was not to the degree that it should
have been
um and they had disproportionate
outcomes for different communities
there's more black folks
who have died from this there are more
latinos who are dying from this this is
this is not fair how about your local
and state officials do you
feel like they've done a better or worse
job than washington on this issue
it's very inconsistent which creates
confusion we
literally have school districts within
ozaukee county that have different
policies about how they're
handling kids going back to school what
makes port washington different from
mequon
you have the liberal areas saying you
know science
shut down forget the economy everyone's
dying
conservative areas are saying uh open it
up
we've got to have an economy freedom and
those neighborhoods are very close to
each other so it's kind of like
within five minutes you can be in three
different zones
of opinion i generally follow the policy
of what my client wants
so when my client shows up in a mask i
put on a mask
if my client asks me to take it off i
take it off everybody
thinks that agrees everything has been
politicized when i see clients
i wear a mask my clients wear a mask in
my office
i have you know hand sanitizer not
because i'm afraid
uh i'd rather be on the safe side why
take a chance
why would i be want to be responsible of
infecting
somebody and that person potentially
could could die
because of how i you know how i do
things
so uh you know and it's i definitely
don't want the economy shut down i want
to see customers i want to take care of
them
i'll see them in my office any time any
day you know but with
with the proper precaution the economy
and the pandemic are
are very much intertwined um
chris talk a little bit about you know
your real estate business
and what you've seen you know when the
pandemics started
i was very nervous and braced for the
worse
the real estate economy which to me has
always been an indicator
obviously for me personally it's my
business um
has been amazing raise your hand if you
thought the economy was
was pretty good in january and february
everybody else has their hands up other
than sabrina she's still
kind of not sure that the economy was
that great now raise your hand again
if you're satisfied with the economy as
it is today
i think so many people i feel look at
the stock market as the economy or what
you're
seeing your 401k but when you look at
milwaukee the
economic inequities the average suburban
you know
those of us in these counties maybe our
economy or whatever is fine
but when you look at the city of
milwaukee in certain areas i don't think
our economy is fine
bernie you work with a lot of uh
immigrants what's your take on sort of
how new immigrants are doing in the
economy right now
definitely not doing very well because
well number one
a lot of the uh immigrants uh didn't
qualify for
for the stimulus checks so overall a lot
of the
the huge latino community is impacted
negatively sue what is your sense as a
as a business owner
just for the the economy sort of writ
large in your area
the economy yes is coming back is it
back 100
in certain fields i i believe it is but
certain fields
it is nowhere near 100 percent you start
having people lose their jobs then they
lose their insurance
you know it's all a chain reaction or a
trickle-down effect
if we don't save our economy it's going
to affect
many many more lives than this pandemic
will
so i do believe that we need to be very
protective of our economy
and get things moving yes do it safely
but we cannot
just keep you know we can't all lock
ourselves in
and and shut everything down it's it's
just
going to be a disaster we've uh
gleaned tonight that there's there's
division here in the suburbs of uh
milwaukee uh differing opinions
you know not unlike the rest of the
country some of you have lived in the
area for long
longer times can you just talk about how
the area is changing and and sort of if
you
sense more political uh
division um as the area has diversified
this community was always very
republican and now
it's you know there's biden signs out
there
i think it's very divided um within
neighborhoods um which we've never seen
before
when i was serving in different duty
stations i've always came back to
waukesha and i've been interested 89
at that time there was very few latino
families
it's grown tremendously over the years
traditionally the latinos vote more
democrat
being aware of the history of wisconsin
and the redlining that caused
the suburbs to stay so white and how
those barriers are starting to be
removed and allowing people to move out
into areas
really allows for a diversity to exist
and i do appreciate the fact that
there's different voices to speak to
different people who are available i do
like
different ideas you know the question
isn't necessarily whether
trump will win these suburban milwaukee
counties he probably will
but it'll depend on how much margin he
gets and and then how that affects the
overall
statewide totals here in wisconsin what
what do you guys
think i see a lot of leadership pushing
people to register and to vote
and if we get everybody coming out and
and we increase the voting
you know we already got a uh we already
got a democrat governor
you know last time so we actually uh i
think that it's going blue
and i see that trend so as long as
people go out and vote i think it'll
that trump will lose in this state chris
what's going to happen in wisconsin
i think trump will do very well in
waukesha county in washington county
ozaukee county is the one that is
i think the closest the question will be
will be there will there be enough votes
rural and rural wisconsin to offset the
huge turnout in madison and milwaukee
and that's usually the game i think
trump will win and i'm counting on it
um i'm nervous but uh i'm hopeful